[Applause]
go away
hi sia that doesn't mean sia but it
means hi in hungarian
i learned that yesterday um so
i'm sold out panades everyone calls me
soleil and i'm super swollen twitter i
decide to add it here so everyone knows
who i
am which i guess if you want to judge me
or whatever you know
who to judge and i work at mozilla you
might have heard about firefox os
it's present in hungary so if you go to
thailand or to a shop in telenor
you can just go out there and buy a
phone so that's cool
we're in 29 countries and 14 global
operators like telenor
orange telefonica so that means that
instead of being this virtual thing that
you can go to ebay and buy like this one
of those weird firefox response you can
actually go to a shop and like try them
before so that's
that's cool because we did all this
thing in just two years
and like we were like okay this is
recall but
i don't know um writing this whole thing
in javascript like this phone
is actually fully written in javascript
except for the parts that interface with
you know like the the drivers and
everything which is c
but it ends up being javascript so
writing all this in javascript and
dealing with all those telcos which are
weird i want your money and all the
things and we still survive
maybe we haven't gone far enough so we
were like okay
so how do we go further
and of course we asked that question and
the answer like
any modern digital agency does nowadays
is we brainstorm
and so we formed like 50 or more groups
there was like this huge list which i
didn't bother
counting because it wasn't like a
northern list so it was 50 or more
and the way it worked was like you could
just like
join groups and it wasn't like normal tv
would be like oh i want to do
this group to experiment about having
more cats
in our phones or you could say oh i want
to experiment
about these other things so there were
lots of different um
ideas and like things you wanted to
think about but
you hadn't had time so they the whole
purpose was to stop for a month
and generate ideas and like kind of like
leave your brain or for whatever so
some of the ideas were obvious like one
of those is streamline the build system
which is like something
like if you've been working on a project
for two months
after two months you want to redo the
whole thing so imagine if you have a
project which
is two years so you want to redo whole
the whole of this
and and the thing is that when firefox
was
started there was power there was
required
like require the the weird one there was
npm
there was many other things but no one
was actually the real package management
system winner
so it's because they couldn't really bet
on anyone they made up their own thing
using sure runner with xpc shell make
files and
all sorts of weird things so when we try
to teach people firefox os two years
after
they actually come from the web and they
look at that and they're like
make files
and they just disappear so we actually
need to fix a thing so that's one of the
reasons we wanted to streamline the
build system make it more approachable
and already is like how do you rest in
the code structure because this is two
years after
there are many apps written in
javascript and each one is written a
different way and new contributors like
might
learn how to use one or how to hack on
one app but then go to the other one and
they're like this is so different i
don't know how to
i need to re learn the whole thing and
there was another thing which is
delivered more polish when firefox was
started there wasn't any web workers
webgl wasn't as stable as it is right
now there wasn't any service worker
so many things were done the old way and
we know that we couldn't do things
way more polished nowadays but we are
not doing that yet so one of the ideas
was like well let's do this thing now so
that was that was all very sensible
but of course i'm not a sensible person
and i'm into the risky ideas
so one of the ideas i like was how do
you rethink smartphones so they are
actually smart
and instead of being this dumb phone
which is interesting interrupting you
all the time
to let you know that you have
notifications or
this one which is really cool suppose
you have a family with
five members and one of them which is
like the rich one has a
proper contract plan and the other ones
are just using players you go why
do everyone have to download the system
update why can't just the contract
person download the system update and
then send it
and share it with all the other phones
because all them are using wi-fi
so this is the kind of ideas that are
very interesting and for people that are
in the first world
as we are it's like why would you want
to do that thing just go and download it
but for people who are in a place where
connectivity is report
this is really cool so these kind of
ideas like okay we have these devices
that can do all these things why are we
not doing this
so that's that was something that was
really really exciting and
also how can you have context our phones
phones that react
and use the sensors to be again more
intelligent
way more interesting that they are right
now so this is
really interesting but the one i really
liked was the peer-to-peer web
and this doesn't have anything to do
with pirating movies or music or
anything like that
but it's about dropping the web and
surfing locally that means that we
should connect to devices we have around
and our phones are super aware of are
super super capable of doing those
things
we are not doing that right now like
today when you want to send data between
devices you often have to send them to
the cloud
and then come back and even when those
devices are like physically closed
as is the case here and this is stupid
or nonsense or however you want to
describe that
but of course that's a business model
for many companies that they love to see
what you're doing they love to look at
your data
and do things i don't know which kind of
things
and actually mozilla has no interest in
doing that kind of thing so we're in a
good position to
actually empower you to control your
data so i was like well
we actually can do this thing because
the people can't because they're
investors or they're
um you know like the important people
are going to say no way you're going to
give people ability to not to show us
what they are doing
so i kept looking at the web pro that i
like
the peer-to-peer prototypes and i was
like okay there is this thing where
people are sharing files between phones
and like
they're sending pictures of their doctor
and it's like that picture is not going
anywhere else other than the adult
network they just created with wi-fi
direct so this is really cool
like dropbox is not seeing those
pictures this is as private as it can
get
and then there was also another version
where someone would be running a sega
mega drive emulator running in
javascript in a phone
and then it would be sending the frames
to another phone or all over like
peer-to-peer
and they could be playing columns one
against the other
and again this was a running javascript
and then there was this other one where
you could just discover devices
with this protocol called wifi direct
and you can just like find things around
you don't even need to set up the
network and that's what they use in
japan and taipei for
configuring uh tvs and devices
so it's like wow this is a javascript
and this is all running on fonts
which means that it makes programming
things for phone really approachable you
don't have to learn
you know like java or objective c and i
of course i'm a thinker and of course i
wanted i was excited and i was like
i want to tinker and make cool stuff and
i want to make it right now
but for once i was a little bit sensible
i was like okay stop and
think what you want to do because i was
going to like start doing things but
nothing would make sense
so i was like okay so peer-to-peer stuff
is very social
and this is going to be a huge challenge
for me because i'm
i tend to do things which are really
anti-social like things are like just
one person playing
with some music or whatever but that's
it
so we'll be like okay i need to learn
how to do things where more people can
play
and then there's also this thing where
people say oh javascript is the story
language where you cannot do anything
serious with javascript
it's like well this is another challenge
let's show them that we can actually do
something serious with javascript
and then finally if you know me you know
that i don't like i love music
so i kind of like joined the whole
things together and it's like okay so
what about
musical toys well if i can just build
something that can run on phones and
it's musical
and it's social as well and
we are not going to need the internet
once we have this thing
we don't need to be connected to
anywhere to play this is not like
playing
a ps3 or ps4 you need to download three
gigs before you can get to the menu
um and if we do this thing right with
service workers and the kind of things
you can even keep the toys afterwards so
we are kind of
multiplying the resources and this was
super super super cool
i was super excited um so
i was like okay we are going to make a
band this is going to be
better than laptop musicians we are
going to be the disconnected and symbol
so i'm kind of like recruiting people on
each
of these situations so today we're going
to have a friend which is waiting here
because bands are more than one person
so it has to be social
so the question is how do we make this
thing happen and there is
a plan of course and the first one is we
make the musical toys then we put them
on a device
then we make them available to other
devices and then we play music and have
fun
so that's four easy steps so the first
one
is making the musical choice and we are
going to go like super modular here and
so we're splitting things around so each
toy is actually two parts
the first one is a web audio based or
you know so all the music side is built
in just one module
and the web component based ui which is
all the things we see
so the web audio knows i don't know if
you know about web audio but
webod is really modular it's about
having this number of
sources of sound and you can connect
them to others boxes that can filter
modify
the sources of sound you can like ending
up like sending all this into this kind
of sync which is actually called the
destination so this is kind of like this
stream that ends up in the
destination which is actually the
speakers and this is really really good
for
making toys because we can just do one
of those boxes and connect it to
existing things and we can reuse code
which is really really neat
so as i say one toy is going to be one
audio note
and i'm basing this on the open music
pattern which is another project i'm
working on
and the idea is that you take another
context which is kind of like the
equivalent
it will do you know to canvas context so
that gives you tools and methods
and it will return you an audio note and
you can just connect it
to anything in the graph so in this case
for example i've got this
theremin and i'm using browserify so
everything is like node
and i'm using i'm requiring that i
create the other context then i
create that new theorem with this thing
and then it's just javascript object so
i can just say start or change the
properties and
like that kind of thing so that's pretty
natural and
and then for the web component ui i know
web components are confusing and like
very esoteric but essentially
this is something that really works well
with representing ui things
and since audio notes have these
properties and these
events that they are made we just need
to
build a custom element that represents
this particular component
and and that that's all we need so
custom elements if you haven't gone into
web components
this is a part that lets you define it
lets you define new types of dom
elements so the browser knows about this
new thing
and just as you can do a new cr you can
do create element table you can also say
create element of a music firm in ui
so this is something i just taught the
browser and the browser knows how to do
that thing
and once you have the element you can
append it you can append it to the body
or do any other thing you would do with
an html element the only special thing
here is the attach to method which is my
kind of own convention
and you would see that i'm attaching
that to the theory node which is
the web audio thing we created before
and
we're doing these things so that we set
up the listeners
on on events on the audio like suppose
you have a node which is playing a
sample
you need to know when that thing is
finished so you can play you can
activate the play button again
and then you can also add listeners for
events on the interface
so if you play if you press play the
thing gets to play again so you need to
get everything in sync
so that's about what you need actually
to do and the other good thing
is because both things are not like you
are writing one thing without actually
depending on the other
and if you are better at ui programming
than me which is super easy because i'm
really bad at that
you can write a better ui element and
just replace it
and you just attach your ui element to
my audio node
or if you have an audio note which is
pretty similar you can just
attach this ui to another audio node and
use the same interface so that's really
really cool
or you could just use the audio
somewhere else like you don't really
really even need to use the ui
you can just like program everything
because this is just a javascript object
and that's how i'm actually writing the
tests like making sure that things work
i don't even have the ui yet i just send
properties and that's how i make sure
that it works um
so this is not too peer-to-peer at all
this is just normal code that works in
any other modern browser which is good
because that means that we can play in
as many devices as we want so the second
step is putting the toys in a device
and we have code that works everywhere
so we just make a static website
like something like this and then that's
it
that's when it because we actually don't
need any pretty big stuff here we just
need to put things in a way that we can
transmit the data
and we don't want to reinvent the wheel
for this so for magnetos available
we have a website what do we do with
websites we put them on servers
so we need a server and the sad thing or
the good thing is that we cannot build a
server or a normal browser
but firefox os apps have super powers
and the super power we need is the tcp
socket
which is what the http protocol or the
servers
are built on so what about we bundle
a website in on the web server
into a firefox os app so that's a zip
file that we can just like push it
and so it's offline and we install it on
the master device which is going to be a
nexus 4
which is flash with firefox size and
that should be it and the good thing is
that someone had actually written a web
server so i didn't have to do it myself
i can just use it and the way you use it
is pretty like node-like you just
require that
then create an instance and you start it
and this is the port we're using the 80.
but this web server would accept
requests but wouldn't reply to them
because we haven't set up any listener
or anything
so we need to respond to the requests
and the way we do it is to just stop
an event listener and just request and
that's it
and how you process the request it's up
to you because this server is not
dictating what you want to do
but it doesn't even know how to parse
the
logic i mean the roots or whatever
you're sending it so we need to do it
ourselves
so what we are actually wanted to do we
want to just serve static content
so that means like if you request a
directory we are just
sending you index.html that means if you
request something that ends with a slash
this is a directory in like html terms
and likewise if you request a file you
need to re
like serve the contents of that file so
it's like if that thing doesn't end with
a slash
so that's that's pretty easy and but
actually before we send anything we need
to tell the the browser on the other
side like hey i'm going to send you this
thing which is this content type
otherwise you will get weird results
so we need to find the what what's the
content type of the thing we're serving
and i'm using this super easy thing
which is like i'm using the extension
so if you are requesting something that
ends with html i'm just going to say
this is text html
like what gpg is image jpg
this is naive by works so just use the
simple thing that works
and for actually serving we just say
okay this is the headers
in the response we have from before
which is the function we just made and
we just
choose the utility method from the
server which is send file
and actually what this thing is doing is
it does
an html http request to the server
app because this is all javascript as i
said firefox os is all written with
javascript
and once you get the contents it sends
the response to the other browser it's
kind of like
this super hack that actually works
so for connecting to the server you need
to find the ip
and one way of finding the ip is you go
to the
phone and go to settings wi-fi
available networks currently work and
you tap again
and you find the ap there is but that's
kind of like
but you could actually use the most
wi-fi monitor with it's another api you
can only access in firefox os
so with that um api you can access
interesting import important information
that you need to show in the screen so
you can find the
uh ip address and the name of the
network and it's also interesting to see
the esthetics of the network because
sometimes it's disconnected or trying to
connect so
your thing is not really available yet
so that's the things that we're going to
show in the server so when i start the
server i will just see that thing and i
can
like look at that from my other phone
and just like
type in the ip address and that's how
you end up with
from this ip address to this other phone
that gets this thing served to it
but that's cool we have the thing it
works
but you know like typing ip addresses is
not my idea of fun
like it's like slow like i don't know
even typing that thing in a computer is
like you know like numbers and because
i'm not an english
native if someone dictates me the
numbers i cannot really remember so i'm
like wait
wait wait can can you just say this
thing is slower because i can't really
remember
so this is like i don't want to be
typing in addresses
so there was a way that you could reduce
this friction
and the way you use nfc and what nfc
means
is near field communication is this
thing that people don't really know how
to use for
and so it lets you transmit small pieces
of data between devices and what people
usually use it is to send you contact
data like
that's where i want to send to to get my
phone to touch some other people
who i don't know phone is like
[Music]
so the things that nfc enabled devices
when they get the url
they navigate to that url and so when
you send one of those small pieces of
data you can say this thing i'm sending
you is a url
so if you type that phone is going to
say oh you're sending a url i'm just
going to open this thing
and actually firefox source apps can
control the web nfc so they can actually
send you things
so as a well let's add this new feature
to this web server which is running on
this
phone so this phone is becoming a web
server that also sends you
urls when this device touches me
so we won't need to type and that's
really cool
so the support again is this is
narrowing now like we are
having support to in nfc in firefights
android somebody told me windows 1 i
don't know because i've never used one
um an iphone 6 plus could
work but apple are keeping the chip
themselves for payments so i know apple
apple
i don't know um so i think it's
now the time for the demos and that's
when i'm going to call my friend
[Laughter]
and we're going to try and show you what
we have right now
so i guess we need to see the camera
right now
um cool cool
so this is this web server i don't know
if you can see this thing
here's the ip address of the server
there are all the three phones are
connected to the network which is
on my other phone so i have a
hotspot running here so i didn't need to
depend on the wi-fi network here
and this is the messages because i've
been trying this thing before and this
is
all the things that i'm replying like
responsing to people so we're going to
try and see we can
have this thing working so maybe you
should show the screen
show it here yeah and hopefully when i
bump it he will get the
you yes you went wow
so he's getting the the choose he can
choose and he's going to choose the
ceremony because this is like
a ceremony this is like this weird
instrument from the 50s
and you can maybe play with it
and yeah yeah yeah and then i'm going to
try and do the same thing and praying
works
okay cool yesterday in the hotel
everything broke and i thought it was
going to be a disaster
um okay there we go so i'm going to
control
a drum machine if it wants to work okay
cool so this is where the disco party
starts okay we are going to remove this
thing so it's more progressive
and more like step by step okay are you
ready for this
yeah let's party are you going to mc as
well oh no i'm not much of a rapper okay
okay okay there we go
there we go
[Music]
do you want to go slower i can chase the
vpm as well
okay
if you want to go faster we can go
faster as well okay maybe faster is
better
[Music]
truth be told this is the first time we
played together so i think
it's thank you it's really cool
yesterday essentially this thing kind of
got confused and it instead of sending
me music instruments it sent me
gifts of cats and then i
installed that thing and this thing and
also went out
and nothing worked and i was like giving
away like
nothing works so yeah so that was
it this is the current state and can i
go back yes thank you um so
of course this is not done by any means
i think that something's not working
well when you connect headphones and it
kind of goes slower so that's weird
and i've got like my next step is to be
able to control
like the bpm in all the devices using
web sockets
so i can slow down everyone at the same
time and
i want to do more toys and obviously
with authoring you can't really go that
far
and also i need to implement service
workers in cash so people can
actually keep the toys and keep playing
when i leave with my master device
and also might be interesting to share
and store the presets so if
like the framing you can only change the
octaves but other instruments might have
more complex presets so it might be
interesting to share the good ones with
people
and also in the future brian eye doesn't
really work too well but you
should be able to like not actually need
to
have this fire spot and set everything
up which i had to do before when you
were having coffee
in the future you should be able to do
this thing automatically with more of
those peer-to-peer apis
and maybe we want to also send the input
events so we record everything and we
upload it to bandcamp and get rich
this isn't that cool and so also
that thing which is also interesting is
we should be able to connect
to the master device automatically
instead of having to do this manual
thing
but right now there's a limitation of
firefox where you can only set two
network like one device to another
device right now instead of
one device to multiple devices so right
now it's not working and that's why i
need to use the hotspot or maybe using
udp sockets with openstack control and
sending things to media devices so i
mean i've got more things like this is
not the only
stuff i've got so it would be nice to
control everything with javascript
and i don't know i might have more ideas
and so
if you want to hack on this or are
curious whether just talk to me or
don't talk to me just use bits and
pieces everything is in github or
use everything if you want to like if
you want to be an artist with this i'm
super happy about that
all i'm saying in other words is do
whatever you want
because this is the web and you should
be able to do whatever you want no one
should be telling you what to do what
not to do and so i'm collecting
resources and things on peer-to-peer
apis on this repository
and thanks
[Applause]
couch time um i didn't see any questions
on twitter
cool and i'm surprised because my first
question is
how can i join the band oh
you just need a device i can't i just
need to bump things though
so i don't know if i'm a good that's
fine i don't know if you want a banner
everyone is invited okay cool great
now i'm happy uh questions please
i can't see anyone oh there's a question
over there
in the front second row
so thanks for the inspiring presentation
it was indeed quite fascinating
uh i wasn't too impressed yet with your
setup with all those wires and mixers
and that kind of stuff
do you imagine would it be possible to
somehow
transmit also the audio data back to the
master device
somehow in sync so that that
you could only use the master device
audio output
to get result that could be possible
using webrtc probably but i had to
use a hack this is a physical hack right
now
yeah in the future i would like to not
to have all those wires it's really
inconvenient especially when you travel
people are like wow yeah it would be
like kind of like more uh more
impressive that way but
i i doubt if if that's kind of
possible to transmit the data fast
enough to get it
we should be able to connect the output
of the thing to a stream and just say
what we are to see
more questions
maybe someone upstairs no
can't see anyone come on
no yeah there's a question over there
could you do um anything in the part of
the discovery of the other devices
with that rtc data channels
or i guess you still you have to have a
web server or
i don't understand the question webrtc
allows you peer-to-peer communication
but
could you use that instead of the
the tcp web server on the firefox phone
you could but you need to establish a
way to start the communication so the
server
it's a natural thing like if i wanted to
do that thing i would need to find a way
to
send the data and parse it and
everything why not just just a web
server
yeah so the good thing is that the way
if other devices don't support
the whole webrtc thing works
and not all devices support nfc if you
do all your stuff you can use an ap
address
or you could maybe do
more than analog modem sounds
and then the other phones yeah you could
get it
yeah but then you don't have time to
write the music things
so you have to choose you need to choose
something yeah okay
one more
yay there it is
oh there we go hi thanks for the
presentation it was really
nice and inspiring
really kind so
if i want to hack on this how can i do
it do i need a firefox os
phone for this or you actually don't
need
well yeah you need if you want to have
the server that sends you things but the
app and all the things
don't really need anything specific like
i'm actually developing
in the browser and i try everything in
the browser and
like you can hack on individual things
that's if you want to have the whole
thing of having the server running on
the phone and everything
but you don't need that if you don't
want to be portable
okay cool i can see a question right
there
so we're going to roll with it
hello do you think you could do live
performances with it
do you think there is enough performance
in these devices to do
like multiple sounds and generate this
in real time so uh do you think there
is yeah well that's the whole point
having a way to just go somewhere and
say like let's go play music
and cool if it doesn't crash which right
now it does a bit
thanks awesome i guess we're done with
questions but that was
absolutely amazing and i hope everyone
is excited about making music with
hardware
i am but i suck at music so i don't know
if i'm
okay now i'm in the band so i don't know
how that will work obviously
uh thank you so long